how do you propose to make this
investigation
well I've established contact and
created some familiarity with the
Klansmen over the phone I'll continue in
that role but only another officer
surprise surprise a white officer to
play me when they meet face to face
that's my point exactly chief black Ron
Stallworth over the phone white Ron
Stallworth face to face so there becomes
a combined Ron Stallworth can you do
that I believe we can with the right
white man we can do anything
remote driving system activating wait
which side of the road is it was Bostick
just right he come to
and look at your suit you've been taking
bullets charging it up with us
put around the truck
sure stamp to this beat come on now I
want you to clap on the third beat
what's going on you know if you're on
time I want to give the audience a song
that they can perform so what can I do
imagine thousands of people doing this
indecent what's the lyric
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm ready for the Russian ambassador who
did your makeup
we weren't something dramatic you like
it you look like a badger oh are you
going to cry really well what do you
think you look like but do you really
think you can meet the Russian
delegation looking like that no I will
manage it look about your rooms thank
you did you look at me did you look at
me Emily
how dare you yes my mother always said
what kind of brand new fool are you
forget them over there take a look look
at officer you hit look at him he's over
there having a grand old time chatting
up with his pals enjoying a nice cup of
coffee and where are you in here with me
who did nothing yet I'm the one who pays
the price I'm the one who's gonna miss
the Birmingham show yeah I'm gonna lose
a lot of money to you don't play
Birmingham so that little temper tantrum
was it worth it hmm you never win with
violence Tony you only win when you
maintain your dignity dignity always
prevails
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
tell me something boy puncher tired
trying to fill that void
Cordelia need mom ain't it hard keepin
it's so hard that mean that's he uses
read that now yeah pretty good I started
writing this song the other day maybe
that could work look as a chorus or
something I'm off the deep end
watch as I dive in I'll never meet the
ground
[Music]
crash through the surface where they
can't hurt us
we're far from the shallow now gotta
tell you a secret I think you might be a
songwriter and don't worry I won't tell
anybody but I'm not very good at keeping
secrets
you
be my VP you solution to my problem CEO
of a large company I have been Secretary
of Defense I have been the chief of
staff the vice presidency is mostly a
symbolic job right right I can see how
that wouldn't be enticing to you
however the vice presidency is also
defined by the president if we were to
come to a different understanding
uh-huh
[Music]
I listen the sense that you're a kinetic
leader you make decisions based on
instinct
I am people I said that yeah yeah very
different very different from from your
father in that regard now maybe I can
handle some of the more mundane jobs
overseeing bureaucracy managing military
energy foreign policy that sounds good
[Music]